when Betsy Bruna and I decided that I
would put on an exhibition the patent
models here in the building a few years
ago we thought this was a no-brainer
because we could go to the Smithsonian's
National Museum of American History and
borrow some of its 6,000 patent models
well we tried that in the answer was so
sorry he can't lend any so in
desperation we turn to our friends in
the US Patent Office and they said you
should contact alan roth child in
Cazenovia New York who owns the largest
private collection of American patent
models in the world so we did just that
and I went up to Cazenovia
for two days in Allen and couldn't have
been more gracious more cynical more
helpful and Alan they had built us wing
on their house to display the patent
models and Alan said borrow anything you
like and so I spent two days selecting
it was hard choice narrowing it down to
40 models but I did and as you know the
exhibition was a great success here for
two years so that's my personal contact
first contact with the Rothschilds but a
bit about Alan Alan received a degree in
pharmacy and went into the family
pharmacy businesses his father had
established three pharmacies in the
Syracuse New York area so Alan was going
to do that for a career but while he was
in college he began he was interested in
apothecary shops and the display the
objects would go into an apothecary shop
and he decided to create an historic
apothecary shop Museum which he did and
was open for 25 years in Syracuse it's
now housed in the Museum of Science and
Technology in downtown Syracuse but he
got bored with pharmacy which he
described as counting pills from one big
bottle into a little bottle so he went
out on his own
and he founded a medical equipment and
supply company
he established a home health care sitter
and also a company to build and manage
medical buildings of which were a
success
he holds two US patents for timing
devices and he's also an inveterate of
course collector patent models I mean on
a massive scale as you well know and
she'll tell you about that in his talk
his wife and I holds a master's degree
in instructional technology and was the
director of senior citizens programs for
the city of Syracuse and she also has
run the family business the Syracuse
Eirik use glove factory and his assisted
Allegan with his research on patent
models and of course she is the
co-author of the book on their patent
model collection titled inventing a
better mousetrap with that let's welcome
Alan Rothschild
[Applause]
Thank You Charles for your kind words I
would like also give a very special
thank you to Betsy Bruin the Margaret
and Terry stent director of the
Smithsonian American Art Museum for
inviting us to do this presentation in
book signing Betsy has always been a
staunch advocate of the patent models
and her support is very much appreciated
thank you to Nona Martin from the museum
who is overseeing the arrangements for
tonight's event a special thank you to
Elizabeth Doherty the director of
inventor education for the US Patent and
Trademark Office and for their
collaboration to make this event happen
also a very well deserved thank you to
Gareth Brandon the editor of our book
who also wrote the introduction for the
book I believe Gareth is here this
evening along with Gretchen Giles from
California representing the publishers
of our book maker media incorporated
thank you both Gareth and Gretchen and
also I want to thank all of you were
will come tonight to hear our program
the patent system added the fuel of
interest to the fire of genius this
quote was by Abraham Lincoln President
Lincoln actually had a patent its
purpose was to lift boats over shoals
and obstructions in a river Lincoln is
the only American president that ever
obtained a US patent
it's April 10th 1790 President George
Washington has just signed a bill to
create the United States Patent Office
for the first time in American history
the right of an inventor to profit from
his or her invention is recognized by
law the Constitution article 1 section 8
Clause 8 empowers Congress to promote
the progress of science and useful arts
by securing for limited times to authors
and inventors the exclusive right to
their respective writings and
discoveries the subject matter of United
States Patent is defined as any useful
art manufacture or device or any
improvement there on that before known
or used to apply for a patent a
specification and drawing and a model
are to be submitted Secretary of State
Thomas Jefferson Secretary of War Henry
Knox and Attorney General Edmund
Randolph are chosen to head a three
member patent Commission commission
members are given the power to issue a
patent if they deem the invention or
discovery sufficiently useful and
important for a period not to exceed 14
years the board's authority to grant
patents is absolute with no appeals
process the Department of State is given
the responsibility for administering
patent laws the fee for a patent is
between four and five dollars this is an
example of a patent model all the images
of models in this presentation are
patent models that are in the book in
our part of the rostral patent model
collection models were required from
1790 until 1880 many were still being
submitted until the late 1890s the model
was not to be more than 12 inches square
and needed to have the inventors name
affixed to it the United States was the
only country in the world that ever
required a model to be submitted for a
patent
during the patent model error the Patent
Office affixed a patent and a receiving
tag to each model that was granted a
patent the patent was attached to the
model they a short length of red twill
fabric tape and the expression
government red tape may have had its
origin from this practice the patent tag
had the patent number on it along with
the inventors name what the patent was
for and the date on which it received a
patent the receiving tag had the
inventors name on it what the patent was
and the date the model was received by
the Patent Office approximately 10,000
models were issued from 1792 18-6 the
patent papers that were issued to the
inventors were each signed by the United
States President the Secretary of State
and the Attorney General the image
displayed is an original patent paper
signed by George Washington on January 6
1797 for the invention of John Lazaro
for a process relating to the making of
compound pot and pearl ashes in 1810 the
Patent Office moves from the Department
of State to Blodgett hotel also known as
the great hotel in Union Pacific Hotel
it was built in 1793 by Samuel Blodgett
and E Street between 7th and 8th Avenue
for the first time patent models are put
on public display and it becomes a local
custom to stroll through the rooms and
Sundays to see what new models are on
view on December 15th 1836 there is a
fire in the patent office and the entire
building burns to the ground all the
records and most of the models are
destroyed Congress appropriates a
hundred thousand dollars for the
restoration of 3,000 of the most
important ones luckily enough records
are held outside the office to allow
almost all the 10,000 models to be
reconstructed they are given their
original date and an X
after their number the X signified the
patent was issued prior to July 1836 in
1836 Congress authorizes construction of
a new building for the Patent Office the
design is a Greek Revival structure
modeled after the Parthenon in Athens as
many of you may know we are now actually
sitting in this building that was built
to house the Patent Office Congress set
certain requirements for the new
building
it must be fireproof meet the
requirements of the Patent Office for
the next 50 years and include galleries
for displaying bottles to the public by
the end of the 1840s as many as ten
thousand visitors per month came to view
the models the patent act of July 4 1836
reestablishes the examination system of
1790 the submission of models are once
again required by the commissioner the
application fee is $30 for u.s. citizens
$500 for British subjects and $300 for
all others a numbering system is
instituted replacing the previous
practice of just using names patent
number 1 is issued to Senator John
Ruggles of Maine for traction wheels i
locomotive steam engines yep
it wasn't supposed to happen but it
certainly did on September 24th 1877 a
major fire breaks out on the first floor
of the West Wing of the patent office
building of the supposedly built
fireproof building 87,000 models are
destroyed 27,000 models are retrieved
from the debris of the fire and Congress
appropriates $45,000 for their
restoration in the summer of 1994 I
stumbled upon a group of patent models
for sale at an upstate New York antique
show completely captivated by them I
purchased a few models and then a few
more and then a whole lot more this was
the beginning of the Rothschild patent
model collection in the passing years
models were added to the collection from
auctions private sales in several other
collections twenty-one years later the
collection consisted of over 4,000
patent models over the years the
collection has been featured in hundreds
of articles and stories and magazines
and newspapers and the Internet some of
the more interesting stories were in the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
Forbes magazine the Christian Science
Monitor the robb report and the inflate
magazine of Emirates Airways the
collection was also featured on
television programs CBS Sunday morning
with Charles Osgood the History Channel
modern modern marvels and home and
garden television I have curated more
than 24 bible exhibits that have
traveled throughout this country some of
the exhibits have been at the United
States Patent and Trademark Office the
Federal Reserve Bank of Boston Maker
Faire in New York Texas A&M University
the Louisiana Art & Science Museum and
without a doubt the most significant of
all the exhibits was the exhibit
inventing a better mousetrap that was
actually in this building the
Smithsonian American Art Museum from
November of 2011 until November 2013
also one of my favorite exhibits which
is still ongoing
is that the Discovery arcade at Disney
Paris the one question that I've been
asked many many times over the past
years is how did I end up with these
models if they were in the possession
and the property of the United States
Patent Office the answer is in 1883 the
models were moved out of the Patent
Office and placed in storage it was
estimated that from 1884 to 1925
$200,000 was spent and moving and
storing the patent models Congress
appropriated $10,000 to do away with the
stored models on December 3rd 1925 the
models were sold at public auction in
New York City the philanthropist Sir
Henry welcomed the founder of the
borough's welcome drug company now part
of Glaxo welcome welcome died in 1936
his dreams of establishing a patent
model Museum never materialized with the
1929 stock market crash the welcome the
states all the models to a Broadway
producer who in turn sold the collection
to a group of businessmen that founded a
company called American patent models in
1940 American patent models declared
bankruptcy and the models were acquired
by Oh Randall Gilbert over the years
Gilbert had many options and thousands
of models were sold in 1979 cliff
Peterson a designer inventor within the
aerospace industry purchased Gilbert's
remaining collection of models Peterson
printed an eight volume set of catalogs
showing pat and models for sale and sold
many models and private sales and
auctions I began purchasing models from
Peterson in 1994 and eventually ended up
with his personal collection
at this time I'd like to give you an
overview of the book inventing a better
mousetrap written by myself and my wife
and there are 25 chapters in the book
broken down by subject matter such as
steam mining home manufacturing
agricultural and various other subjects
each chapter reviews the history of the
subject as it relates to its
significance during the 1800s and the
Industrial Revolution in the u.s. each
chapter also features a dozen or more
pad models with short descriptions of
how they work along with stories about
their inventors our book has had over
three dozen reviews and comments all of
which have been extremely complimentary
and informative I'd like to share one of
the comments with you by somebody whose
name you will all recognize the
Rothschild patent model collection lets
us see how different our lives would be
without the spirit of invention seeing
what other inventors have done is what
motivates to think outside of the box
and to look at life differently do we
want a watch Life go by or be part of it
Steve Wozniak co-founder of Apple
computers
I'd like to talk now about a few of the
inventors featured in the book along
with images of their models George
Corliss was known worldwide for his
contributions to the design and
construction of the steam engine in 1847
he established the Corliss nightingale
company in Providence Rhode Island of
all the thousands of steam engines built
at the coriolis Factory the most famous
was one at the 1876 Centennial
Exhibition in Philadelphia the steam
engine was the largest in the world and
supplied power to 14 acres of machinery
the patent model this patent model is
the Coriolis gear cutting machine patent
in 1877 the machine was adapted to cuts
to cut large bevel gears with any
required degree of bevel this is the
machine that was on display at the 1876
Centennial Exhibition the previous slide
Eli Whitney the inventor of the cotton
gin was born in Westborough
Massachusetts in 1765 his father for
whom he was named was a farmer in 1794
Whitney revolutionized the cotton
industry with his invention for removing
seeds from cotton fiber Eli Whitney's
son also named Eli was born in 1820 and
was 5 years old at the time of his
father's death when his father passed
away he too became known simply as Eli
Whitney not jr. in 1841 son Eli his
portrait is on the screen took over the
operation of the musket manufacturing
from his cousins the Blake brothers we
will talk about next
Whitney's patent model was fraying new
and improved breech-loading firearm he
received many patents over a 30-year
period and was one of the first
manufacturers of percussion gun caps son
Eli Whitney died in 1894 at the age of
74
the first live company in New Haven
Connecticut was Blake brothers company
started in 1833 by three brothers Eli
Whitney Blake Silas flake and John Glee
nephews of Eli Whitney the inventor of
the cotton gin
after Whitney's death in 1825 the Blake
brothers took over the operation of the
gun factory and as I just mentioned
Whitney's son Eli took over the
operation from his cousins in 1841 in
1858 Eli Whitney Blake invented the
first stone and wreak crushing machine
which provided the material to build the
nation's first fave road waste this
achievement earned the Eli Whitney Blake
the title father of the American Road
system the Blake brothers escutcheon
latch patented by them in 1833 was the
world's first mortise lock and latch
that was inserted into the body of the
door their invention replaced the box
lock and latch that was affixed to the
outside surface of the door Sir Henry
Stevens Maxim was born in Sanger's Field
Maine in 1840 while born in America he
later became a British citizen maxim
received his greatest recognition for
inventing the world's first automatic
portable machine gun his gun could fire
500 rounds per minute equal to the
firepower of a hundred rifles the maxim
gun revolutionized warfare he offers his
weapon to the United States war and navy
departments both of which declined it on
the ground that it was impractical the
following year maxim sold his gun to
most of the major powers in Europe in
1900 he was knighted by Queen Victoria
becoming Sir Henry Maxson and
recognition of the contribution his gun
had played in the success of the British
Army
Maxon was a prolific inventor from
inventing the first automated sprinkler
system to flying a plane before the
Wright brothers it was in Brooklyn New
York where maximum developed machines
for generating and illuminating gas
establishing the maxim gas company his
invention for the carburetor was an
automated machine for carburetor air for
illuminating purposes by converting
gasoline into a vapor under and pressure
now Melville Bissell and his wife Anna
were partners in a cracker East or the
Chyna products arrived in crates packed
with sawdust the packing material
frequently would spill onto the floor
and needed to be constantly cleaned up
Bissell was frustrated with the sweeper
he was using and in 1876 patent has
improved Bissell carpet sweeper Melville
Bissell died in 1889 at the age of 45
upon his death his wife Anna became the
head of the company becoming the first
female CEO in America the Bissell carpet
sweeper was patented in 1886 the drive
wheels they turned the rotary brush
shaft were located outside the N walls
of the sweeper casing the casing was
surrounded with an encircling elastic
band for for preventing the drive wheels
and said casing from coming in contact
and marring furniture or wall surfaces
the Bissell company is still in
existence today in Grand Rapids Michigan
and is still family-owned in 1843 at the
age of 19 a young Quaker named Steven
Whitman set up a small confectionery and
fruitier shop close to the waterfront in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania trying to
compete with the fine European chocolate
of the time he drew customers from all
walks of life but it was the sailors
from the nearby Wharf who provided
Whitman with the imported fruits nuts
cocoa and flavorings from their travels
he incorporated all of these delicacies
into his chocolate Whitman began his
company selling individual chocolates
but in 1854 he introduced his first box
of candies Whitman's choice mix sugar
plums from Steven F Whitman packaged in
a frilly pink container adorned with
rosebuds and curly hues it became the
first packaged confectioner in a printed
trademark packaged sugar plums at the
time referred to any candy not just one
type Whitman patented his machine for
casting confectionery in 1875 the
machine used a steam film box
surrounding the body to heat the
pre-molded batch which was to be poured
into multiple but vessels located on the
top a lover a lever controlled a sliding
gate underneath to control several
streams of material simultaneously as a
testament to Steven Whitman 160 years
later the Whitman name is still
synonymous with chocolate Richard Howe
was an American press maker who in 1843
invented the rotary press which really
revolutionized printing the press the
rotary press printed both sides of a
sheet of paper at the same time the
first rotary press could print up to
8,000 pages in our larger rotary presses
made printing large run newspapers
possible whole received over 30 patents
for his inventions his inventions were
responsible for the company becoming one
of the most successful manufactures of
printing equipment in North America hos
patent model for printing railroad
tickets is one of the most elaborate and
rare models in the rothschild patent
model collection today 12 models by
Richard Howe are at the National Museum
of American history I believe this is
the only other existing whole model that
is not in that collection this press
using a revolving cylinder numbered the
tickets with successful sets of numbers
by registered by a registry apparatus
and then cut them from the roll into
posited them and a receptacle in
numerical order
Henriette vest Vassar dearth of
Englishmen England is known as England's
first women engineer and her improvement
in propeller designs is probably the
most important Dada chol invention of
the 19th century in 1838 Henrietta's
father James Lowe had patented his idea
of a submerged stem mounted propeller
the low propeller was fitted on many
British warships while following her
father's death dancer Turk carried on
his pioneering work and the development
of the screw propeller for steamships
her propeller was used in many worships
and liners including the Scandinavian
and the Lusitania
on May 4th 1869 banzer turret received a
United States patent for her method of
construction for screw propellers her
propeller allowed ships to go faster
with less fuel less vibration and better
steering in Reverse the Civil War
changed the fields of military surgery
and orthopedics the powerful destructive
and more accurate weapons of this
conflict did more damage to the human
body than ever before resulting in not
only more injuries but injuries of a
more critical nature beginning in 1862
the federal government provided money to
Union amputees with which to purchase
artificial limbs amputees were given $50
for an arm and $75 for a leg and the
state of North Carolina a resolution was
passed in 1866 to begin a program
similar to the federal one to supply
legs to Confederate Veterans
the state of North Carolina contracted
withdrew its patent leg company to
supply artificial legs to its amputees
the leg that was supplied was his
artificial leg patent number 35,000 686
June 24 18 62 this is the actual patent
model for Jewett's artificial leg that
ended up being given to the Confederate
soldiers of the state of North Carolina
the Steinway piano company was started
in New York City in 1853 it was a family
business from by Henry Steinway along
with some of his eight children
Christian Steinway the eldest of the
five sons was a brilliant meticulous
engineer and scientist he accelerated
the pace of invention research and
development within the company and was
responsible for 45 of the firm's 101
patents this patent model of the CAPA
destro frame for the piano was one of
Christian Stein ways most important
inventions the all brass frame covered
the width of the piano a wire was
attached to each key that went over the
bar then under and back over again and
was then attached to a tuning peg this
was the first invention that helped to
keep each note in - it was eventually
copied by every piano manufacturer in
the world at this point I've gone
through a very abbreviated synopsis of
some of the first 23 chapters in the
book it's time now for some fun so
chapter 24 is a visual quiz of 25 models
to see if you can guess what the
invention is so let's try one and see
how you do please raise your hand if you
think this is a a circumference
measuring device
be a helium eater see a rocking cradle
and be a coin sorter it looks like a
coin sorter got the most votes and
unfortunately if you said coin sorter
you're wrong
it is a helium eater and a helium etre
is a type of a sundial so now you know
at least one correct answer on the quiz
another unusual and innovative part of
the book is chapter 25 six pot six
patent bottles you can make the models
are an electromagnetic motor a
reversible lounge a mousetrap of course
a pigeon starter a robo and a washing
machine complete instructions are
included to allow the reader to build
their own replica of the model using 3d
printing conventional techniques and
other methods and materials one of the
models you can replicate is the pigeon
starter your you'll probably be thinking
what the heck is a pigeon starter at the
time this patent was issued in 1875 live
pigeons were used for target practice
and placed in traps dug it into the
ground just below grade level
however opening the trap was often not
enough to make the pigeons fly up or
even leave the trap yelling and throwing
stones at the pigeons were common
methods of starting the pigeons but
affected the shooters concentration this
pigeon starter made a loud noise and
included a cat Lake figure that moved
from a crouching position into an
upright stance to startle the birds into
flight
soon after the patent was issued the
shooting of light pigeons for sport was
banned the live pigeons were replaced by
a plan andddd clay discs that were then
named clay pigeons the sport took on
name of trapshooting resulting from the
fact that the pigeons were originally
kept in the ground and traps the replica
bottle that you can build looks like
this
the original is like this and once again
the one you can build
at this time I'd like to introduce dr.
gate
David Cole the executive director of the
Hagley Museum & library which is located
in Wilmington Delaware dr. Cole has
written afterward in the book what's
next
[Applause]
[Music]
can you hear me very good okay well
you've just heard quite a story you've
actually heard two stories so the first
story you heard told very well by Alan
is a story of American innovation how
the US patent system developed and how
the models became the signal artifacts
in the evolution of innovation in this
country in the 19th century and it's an
exciting story full of fantastic
artifacts fantastic ideas brilliant
inventions and inventors but also as
Alan mentioned it's a bit of a checkered
history right punctuated by some rather
sad events two terrible fires and then a
rather a rather dismal history for the
models beginning in the late 19th
century and into the early 20th century
when sadly they were neglected and their
full value as visual records of American
innovation in what some considered the
Golden Age of innovation in this country
was sadly ignored and even lost but then
you never heard another story and it's a
better story and it's a story about how
handful of people throughout the 20th
century kept the flame alive and
culminating in the marvelous work that
Alan and Anne had done for over 20 years
to gradually with great enthusiasm and
great energy gather together over 4000
of these models and create as Alan
mentioned or as Charles mentioned the
greatest private collection of these
models anywhere in the world really
preserving through these artifacts a
legacy of innovation that would
otherwise have been lost and so we owe
them a great deal for having done this
and now they are passing the baton and
I'm the director of the Hagley Museum
and Library in Wilmington Delaware where
we specialized in interpreting the
history of business and technology and
innovation and we've been doing that for
over 60 years but now we've got some
wonderful new toys to play with
and I'm delighted to say that Alan and
Ann have chosen to bestow upon our
museum both a great honor and a great
responsibility over 4000 of the models
have come their entire collection have
come to the hagley museum and library
and it will be our job and our pleasure
in the years to come
to interpret them to carry on the great
work that they began and that was
accelerated in 2011 by Betsy and Charles
here at this very institution bringing
to the public's attention what a
wonderful legacy of innovation this is
and what marvelous stories there are to
tell through these models about the
history of American innovation and its
going to be our job in the years to come
at Hagley through exhibitions and
educational programs and traveling shows
and documentaries and all kinds of media
to to bring these models and their
associated stories to life really with
two goals one to to further an
appreciation for and an understanding of
innovation in America particularly in
the nineteenth century but also we hope
something else happens we hope that
people of all ages when exposed to these
models and the stories they have to tell
will become inspired to innovate in
their own lives that's really the
ultimate goal and I think it was Alan
who said to me the first time we met
what his dream was what their dream was
for these models and that is that you
hope that someone looks at one of the
models and is inspired to create in
their own right to invent something and
maybe if they get lucky and the stars
align to build a business around that
invention and maybe if they really get
lucky to build a community around that
business that's the vision that we have
with the models that's what we're going
to hope to do in Wilmington Delaware and
beyond in the years to come and I'm just
so we feel so privileged that the
Rothchilds would give us this
opportunity and we hope we don't let you
down in the years to come so thanks very
much and
enjoy the book all of you I recommend it
highly thanks thank you David
at this time I would like to ask if
anybody has any questions I'd be glad to
try and answer them and I've been asked
if you would go through the microphone
too on either side of the auditorium to
ask your question great session
what about raise your hand
hi I'm curious if when you were looking
to build your collection if you came
across any models that for whatever
reason you were interested in adding to
the collection and if so why oh my
mouths were really made up of many many
different collections from private
collections and models at auctions and
from just individuals that maybe had one
or two miles there really wasn't any one
particular model that I would have
wanted except probably for an Edison
model and there were very very few
Edison model patent models he had many
many patents but the reason there
weren't any is because most of the his
inventions were after the model
requirement a little confused about the
dispersion of the models from the Patent
Office some went to the Smithsonian some
one out at auction and some went back to
inventors how did how did all that play
out the models were offered first to the
Smithsonian and then in other
industrialists in what year prior to
1925 that happened and then in 1925 the
bulk of the models were put out
auctioning in New York City and that's
when Sir Henry welcome but but the
entire group of models which were a
couple hundred thousand probably
are the models on display at the heckler
museum now are you the process of
mounting exhibit or what's the status
and there's actually 25 models on
display here at the Smithsonian Ellen
being involved in the Patent Office and
searching and all that a lot of my job
so I do the disclosures are coming in in
video formats and 3d formats and virtual
technologies and of course there's all
these 3d printing going and create going
on at the moment do you think that
models could make it come back I think
that there's a you know our book is
published by make media the company that
sponsors the makers fair throw up
throughout the actually throughout the
world and I think there's a very very
strong interest in you in making and I
think there's a lot of especially young
individuals that are very very involved
I've been to three makers fairs and if
any of you have an interest it's really
humble enough unbelievable and event to
attend and I I don't think there will
ever be a requirement or you know paid
models of a patent office I would defer
to Elizabeth Dority and I think that
model making though I think is very
strong in person at the present time
especially with 3d perfect
I had when I visited your collection in
Cazenovia I remember that you spent
quite a bit resources and money
restoring the patent models and many
many were not restored I just wondered
if there's a program at the Hagley for
restoring those models or what will
happen to them my defer they had to
factor coal we have an object
conservator cuddle them on staff and
Hagley and some models maybe mobile will
tread lightly there will tread lightly
in the interest of you know not not over
restoring and not not attempting to to
remove some of the original qualities
are very practical but as we continue to
unpack them and work our way through
them will be certainly discover
candidate thank you and with the with
the end of the requirement for patent
models is there any history that
indicates that that caused any type of
problem with the approval or issuance or
the understanding of the concepts by the
patent examiner's was there any effect
material effect with the end of the
model requirement I I don't know of any
I've never seen anything written about
that I think that it it basically
probably became overwhelming obviously
the numbers of patents became geometric
each year almost from the very very
beginning so I think by the time the
year on it was mentioned 1870 the Patent
Office said no more models
they were still turned in and great
numbers until 1880 Patent Office and
says we really don't want any more
models
and model-making was a profession at the
time the inventors were used to
submitting models the model makers we
obviously love making the models and so
models were still turned in from 1880
right through 1900 but but in very small
numbers but the answer question I think
the Patent Office is probably glad to
have the young models not being
submitted anymore and the patent
examiner's probably were probably just
as happy also I would guess it was
overwhelming if you can imagine you've
seen some of you have seen the models
upstairs 25 models how much room they
took up just imagine having a couple
hundred thousand miles in this building
that's where that's where they were hi
thank you for the talk I've only seen
models behind glass and I wondered how
functional the models are when you
actually get to touch them because a lot
of them have gears various handles and
it looks like I mean obviously there are
models of actual inventions that are
usually have these moving parts do that
do a lot of the models also have are
they you know basically functional or
most of them just visual representations
Wendy when these models were made by the
plateau model makers they were actually
functioning models that showed what the
claims were for for the invention so
they were functioning at one time they
were miniature but there were moving
parts on the models so the answer is yes
today it would be hard for them to be
still working because they can be up to
over a couple hundred years old
Allen my thanks to you and Ann both for
your beautiful collection and your
generous gift to the public into the
nation to to choose to share this
beautiful gift of your collection and
then to share it in this beautiful book
that's that's now available so more
people can learn and benefit from this
beautiful piece of our history I do have
one question and that is having been bit
by the bug so to speak are you still
buying models that Elizabeth that's a
very very good question and people asked
me that and is it and as I said to David
when we were talking about the
collection I probably should have said I
want to keep out a handful of models but
I knew if I said that we would probably
get into some kind of disagreement on
which models I would keep so I decided I
will just go cold turkey and give up the
whole collection but I just read
recently they say once a collector
always a collector so I have to say that
I have started a new pant and mail
collection
and I have a total of five models or 19
collecting David said how many were was
i planning and collecting and I said I
think I'm going to try for about four
thousand and ten yes I probably will end
up with maybe fifteen or twenty five
models I want to pass them on to our
grandchildren just so they have an idea
how crazy their grandfather really was
Thank You Elizabeth
um you mentioned earlier the word claims
is there any I'm not quite sure what the
right words iconography or any
particular way in these models of
highlighting what the claims of the
patent were I'm not sure what well the
your most models upstairs show
particular devices and quite often the
devices of generic and patents have that
they have claims that I do particular
some particular thing which the model
embodies in some way and I'm wondering
since the modified often may include a
general technology as well as the
particular claims in the patent is it
were there any way of highlighting the
particular claims in in a model well
written papers explained device the
patent papers explain in detail what do
the models provided easy way of seeing
what those claims are all you have to
read AB and understand what if you've
asked for the model papers and read them
carefully and you can match the claims
on to the model there's actually no
question about it but there's no way of
going from the model to see what the
claims are find it by the model by it
cells do that you'd have you'd have to
read you have to read the papers to
understand the claims and then look at
the model and as I mentioned upstairs
earlier silly people say why were their
patent models to begin with the use they
thought was is that it made it easier
for the patent examiner
to see what the inventor was trying to
claim and then when a inventor submitted
a new application for a pet and along
with the model the examiner could take
that new model and naturally physically
take it to where the models were
exhibited and compare the two together
so that was the main purpose of the
origin of why the patent models were
were required but not quite at the time
for one more question other way I could
certainly do you have any sense of the
kinds of patents that people were
applying for changed as a result of the
elimination of the patent model
requirement I think it's time when I
number one most all of the patents that
were patented were improvements they
were there weren't really a tremendous
amount of new patents issued during this
kind we copied England's patent system
and England had a ongoing system and
most everything that was patented in the
US during this period had already been
patented in England so most all of the
inventions during this period of time
were for previous patents but we're
improvements upon them I think as you
know the years went on after the
requirement was gone I think the the
patents became more more complex and of
course as today they're extremely
complex
thank you very much Alan for your
wonderful presentation
our museum shop is open and if you'd
like to purchase a book feel free to go
upstairs and get one and then you can
come down and join us for a brief
reception and talk more with Alan Thank
You Alan thank you all for coming